this reminds me of in sweden
there was a story that i uh when i was
when i i went to sweden several years
ago
you you you yeah i think most people
know but for those that aren't familiar
i went to sweden because donald trump
said you know look what happened over
you know last night in sweden
he was referring to a fox news story
everyone took him literally because
the left likes pretending they you know
they pull him out of context
right so i decided you know with a a
friend of mine
emily we were gonna go and cover and do
like a vlog series in sweden to see
what's really going on we called it last
night in sweden it was funny
we thought it was like we thought it was
like a funny take on going because i
really thought for the most part that
sweden was okay
right and it kind of was it's got its
problems right there's a story there
about someone who committed a crime who
was uh somali
and the media blurred his face and hands
and then changed the color of the pixels
to make it look like he was white i
remember that
yep and i think there's a racial
component to why they don't do certain
stories
this is the problem with the hysterical
media telling a story about a guy
murdering a kid
does not make you racist it is not it's
not racist to highlight the fact that
a grown man executed a little boy i
don't care what their races were i care
that it happened
when when tamir rice you know the story
of tamir rice was playing with his you
know toy pistol in a park
and the cops ran up and shot him i was
extremely angry about this
cops you know that's why i think there's
there's real there's
room for reform and figuring out how to
make you know
things better dude i think this is why
racism is never going to die
they're not going to let it it earns way
too much
money it is way too lucrative it's way
too profitable it gets all those clicks
dude
and this is why they don't want the war
in the middle east to die
exactly for much the same reasons it's
like it's like controlled chaos
let it happen you know but i i really
don't think it's a grand conspiracy
or anything like that i think you know
what we see in places like sweden
and now what we see with stories like
this it is
oh man i'm going to read this i'm i'm
look yeah what
i what i wanted to end with is there are
there there are social functions that
tell you you are not allowed to say
certain things
because it's too close to the line no
matter what and i've been explaining
this
on you know a couple times particularly
how it pertains to covid
if we're not allowed to show you a
doctor talking about kovid
because he's got good news and we get
banned for it then the only thing you
will ever see is
everything's getting worse yep kovit is
getting worse everybody's getting sick
and then people will just continually
believe everything's worse than it is
and then because of that the actions
taken by government
and by doctors will always be towards
the most extreme and negative
interpretation
there's no yeah so you you need you need
arguments so if the news comes out and
says this is the end of the world it's
the apocalypse
you need another side to come out and
say well hold on there's some good news
here and then people can weigh their
the views and say okay i think the truth
is close to the middle right now
anybody who says anything like like this
this is the reason why only conservative
outlets for the most part actually talk
about what happened to this kid
right and i think there's a racial
component to it i think you're right
well i think this so this
this really boggles my mind and and i
don't think i think that the
the fact that the media has no
accounting force
i think what you said about them pushing
everything toward the extreme by only
giving bad news i think that's
that's pivotal like that's an important
point and i'm not sure anyone really
considers that
and i know that you can read the news
all day kind of like we do
and just come away thinking you know
everything's normal because everything's
bad you're normal
your new normal becomes everything is
always bad and you never stop to think
about how
policies are being pushed one way or the
other yep yeah so
i mean look i've had deep conversations
with other big podcasters and and
political personalities
and i'm not i you know people like
people have commented on how i said in
the past
if youtube came and banned me outright
and just got rid of everything
i'm like i'm gonna i'mma hop in the van
i'm gonna buy the river and go fishing
and just
just relax and i don't care if i have to
you know if the rest of my life was
back-breaking labor working on
you know farm to grow my own food and
live a humble life
but it's it's it's it's more about
it's really hard to do right when it
comes to information
how many stories are we not talking
about right now
how many how many other people have been
murdered across this country all day
every day we don't talk about them
and so to be honest when i saw this
first story i'm like man
i'm from chicago you know you show me a
story like this and i roll my eyes and i
say welcome to welcome you know some of
the worst parts of this country these
things happen
and i think for this story people people
took it very seriously and i thought
it would i was perhaps too jaded
and i should highlight this and i should
talk about how the media
has done a poor job fully recognizing
that
i think even coming to the point where i
felt like i should have talked about in
the first place
i feel like i'm just playing into the
same media machine
oh everybody starts talking about it so
then i jump on the train and i'm like oh
you know look now i'm concerned too and
it's like i'm concerned about all of
this all the time
but you know if if you only hear
from me like if you only watch my
channels then you're going to get
basically what i see and you don't see
literally everything i see
so people might have their perspective
skewed by only watching my content
one of the reasons i think youtube is
substantially better than basically any
other news outlet
is because i hear from a lot of people
they don't just watch me
they watch also jimmy dore right or or
crowder
kalkalinski stixxax and hammer other
great creators you know
uh uh commentators and that's like
the youtube platform has created an area
where you have
different opinions sometimes arguing
with each other
and debates so you're not getting
pigeonholed by
one media company that won't tell you
everything and only wants it to be
always negative and everything like that
but i do think it's fair to point out
same goes for me and literally anybody
else man really we only ever talk about
bad things
well to be fair there's only so many
hours in the day there's only so many
stories you can cover like you cover a
lot of stories
you cover what six different stories a
day like often
combining things together and and you
can't cover everything we have like
millions and millions of people in the
country and a 24-hour news cycle
there's just not a way to cover
everything for everyone
but yeah i mean
the whole idea that it's constantly bad
is
kind of discouraging so i don't know how
to fix that the media
i think i think it's look i can be
self-critical i think it's important to
do so
and i think you know people can
criticize me
but i think i still try to do a good job
i still think i do a good job i think we
do a good job
and i want to show you this image right
here and i want to show you what a bad
job is
this is covington catholic 4 million 450
000 results
in a half second canon hidden
187 000 results in a you know 0.3 of a
second
there really is no coverage of this that
like think about what covington catholic
is
covington catholic was literally a kid
standing
smirking and and that was like everyone
and their grandmother came out and they
were like can you believe this
what makes viral outrage you know what i
mean like why
when i got sent that video of covington
people were like dude did you see this
and i was like what is it
and they're like it's this kid and he
like got in front of a guy's face and i
was like
it's just a video of a kid watching a
guy drum i'm just standing there i don't
know what you care
what is this and i'd ignored it and then
when i saw everyone talking about it
i actually started questioning it i
found a video that showed the native
american walk up to the kid
and i was confused i was like what do
you mean like the the the native
american dude walked up to the kid why
is everybody angry about this
right that was national news nobody
wants it you know what
you know what it was a negative racial
component
you're right that's consistent it was i
don't like that i know
and i think the skip gets back to my
point about racism i think this is why
racism will never die
because it just drives the media and it
drives the clicks and it drives the rage
that people already kind of have and
think they know it's part and it's
history
and it's creating a psychotic world view
let me let me show you this paragraph
real quick they say at the time of
publication
a search of canon hidden produced no
results on the websites of abc cbs
nbc msnbc cnn npr new york times the
washington post time or newsweek
it appears that fox news was the only
mainstream media to cover the horrible
death of the five-year-old boy
international news outlets such as the
sun daily mail and the independent have
reported
on the boy's murder we are being poorly
served in this country well let's go to
international places they're covering
yeah i i i don't i don't get it man
i mean i do obviously but what i mean is
like i understand why they do it
right why they why they push the stories
they push
it's it's safe it's safe
it's born out of i think a
somewhat fair like comedic space
where early on you had comics who had no
problem
ragging on white people because it's
like listen man
there's an argument about punching down
punching up and there were comics who
didn't care
they'd punch any which direction they
wanted to right but there was some
you know some things were considered you
know too much like i said if you only
are ever allowed to hear one side of an
argument
then that's the direction you're going
yep and so we we we've come to a point
now where the news
sees this and there i i don't think it's
necessarily uh a racist thing i think
it's more of a
this story lines up with other stories
that get traffic right maybe they don't
even consider
that there's a racial component here
they're just like oh this this has all
the makings i'm not really going to put
my finger on it because i don't care to
think about it too much
but i'm just gonna go with it because i
know this is kind of in in
line with other stuff we've done that's
really really been big yeah
that's it's it's the incentive machine
where like facebook
gives you you get the numbers like
twitter twitter and facebook
you can see those live metrics of your
story doing well
and this results in a negative feedback
loop so these media companies are like
so actually that's a really good example
of mike.com
i'm going to say my understanding and
based on what i've read because i could
be wrong about this and i'm saying that
for legal reasons
but initially they were very like
libertarian and it's really interesting
to look at some conservative
commentators and go back in their
history on youtube
and see how anti-cop there they were
yeah
very critical of police and police
brutality because the libertarians don't
like the state
beating people and having that authority
too now they're very pro-cop
and i do think it's it's not it's not
it's not you know fair to say it's
simply they flip-flopped it's that
there's a difference between saying like
please police stop the violent riots and
supporting you know police brutality or
something yeah because i don't think
anybody supports that
but what ends up happening is you get
sites like mike that would put up a
video of police brutality
and they would get you know they would
see the live numbers and be like whoa
they'd put up a video of you know ron
paul giving a speech in a bit yeah
so they said we know what butter's our
bread pump out that anti-police
you know videos so do you think it's
safe to say that watching what the media
does with their metrics is kind of like
a
a a glorified version of what happens to
people
when they're watching their own metrics
it's like yeah so you know
how you can feel crappy or really great
depending on how people are responding
to stuff that you tweet or talk about on
facebook
you can't have that happen man you
really can't like how do you
get away from that uh strong
fortitude mental fortitude do you think
we should reform 230
as far as the news stories go yeah but i
don't think that's going to change how
youtube
creates um like these feedback loops
yeah it's true it's a little bit
different
i it's so it's so annoying when i hear
like
people saying simultaneously tim is the
slowest red pill ever
and the left saying tim flipped as soon
as he saw a right-wing audience i'm like
this is just so stupid schrodinger's red
pill
it's just not well it's i think if
you're on the left i look like i'm on
the right and if you're on the right i
look like i'm on the left
yeah so it really is like being a
centrist
an optical illusion yeah i it's crazy
when i talk to my friends and they're
like we're all in for biden and i'm like
but he's the establishment politician
who like supported war what are you
talking about and like
he gropes people and he smells girls
like it's weird
too many little factors going on there
you know i
i see that there's these viral facebook
posts one of them going around going
around right now is about
confederate statues and it's a bunch of
facts about the confederacy
and it frames the argument as though
trump likes the confederacy
right you're giving me that you give me
yeah so i'm giving tim this look
because i know and i think you guys
probably also know that the confederacy
was not
part of the republican party this was
never democracy
these were democrats so the the idea of
being pushed by our new historians we
have a new history now because they're
just kind of rewriting it as they go
along
is that um trump wants to what do this
in gettysburg because he wanted to go to
where the
veterans lost i saw i saw a progressive
journalist
tweet out why are you so trump said he
wants he wants the acceptance speech for
the rnc
at maybe gettysburg or the white house
and then this progressive journalist
quote tweeted it and
and said why would you want to hold the
speech where your side lost
and i'm like i read that i was like huh
and so i responded the republicans won
the civil war
yeah what are you talking about
democrats who lost
yeah the democrats were the with the
confederacy but this viral facebook post
is like why are so many people now
defending the confederacy and why is
donald trump talking about their statues
and um yeah and i'm like donald trump
specifically referenced jeff
jefferson and grant yeah and hans
christian hegg and
and other heroes of the civil war
that were republicans i mean jefferson
and
and you know washington weren't because
they didn't exist
right yeah and it was funny somebody
said uh
i saw one of the stupidest tweets man
what did they say four score and seven
years ago was
1933 which was the day of like
you know hitler's ascension or some
other ridiculous
i know and i'm like amazing four score
and seven years ago is that is that what
they're trying to allude to that he's
actually going to gettysburg
the place where where uh the the union
won
and crushed that is some next
level conspiracy theorizing i have to
say that's really impressive
you see what jamie curtis uh posted gosh
yeah
a a mail truck on a flatbed trailer what
and she said
the driver had a red hat with white
letters are
oh oh you mean like towing companies use
to put their
yeah are trump supporters stealing mail
trucks to win the election
yeah probably uh-huh that is the
simplest explanation tim
it's it's it's sometimes i feel like i'm
trying to knock down a skyscraper with a
little ballpeen hammer
like how do you compete with the fake
news machine
when people are spreading memes like
crazy they're just based off of fake
news
trump is not coming out and saying he's
defending the confederacy
he's coming out and saying i was like
listen the argument isn't about for the
most for most people
confederate statues right it's about
having a discussion
having a democratic process to determine
do we take it down replace it
do we leave it up how do we take it down
instead violent mobs are showing up with
rope from other communities and ripping
them from the
from their bases and it's not even just
about the confederates it's it's
literally about grant hunter
christian hag somebody tore down
frederick douglass they turned
it down the elk i don't get it i don't
understand so
there has to be a process by which we
take down statues we don't agree with
and if you don't agree with the statue
of an elk
i'm sorry for you probably should
reinvestigate yourself
seriously what is wrong with you that
thing was like 120 years old that made
me sad
like why because it was built by
colonialism or whatever stupid
that's such an easy answer oh it's built
by colonizers thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you